the Joe Rogan experience were you
excited for I wasn't in China I was in
Hong Kong Singapore and Macau so now the
Macau what's funny is when you're in
Macau which is obviously big casino kind
of tourist destination all the people
there they eyeball immediately who
that's all you who's like a mainland
Chinese person you know because they can
tell about it well that's a different
type of thing where if there's if
somebody's like do you see dudes in
Macau in like Versace shades and like a
Fendi and Gucci and like I mean crazy
outfits you're like God yeah what's up
with that dude and they'll be like
that's just a mainland dude who knew
money he just got rich Wow it's all over
Macau be we just no and then you see
that the I think the understated person
they're like that's a Hong Kong guy
that's old money yeah right well it's
like England almost yeah yeah yeah track
suits and yeah and then you got the old
posh money who's like yeah all right
Loree I'll say on country you do the
accent without saying the words okay
okay go Russia don't say the words just
make the noises they make don't do
anywhere any words the samurai speaking
sasquatch footage no no one of the
dumbest things that Duncan and I did we
were doing that you know no we went and
studied Bigfoot one of the dumbest
things like our I did the show with me
mm-hmm and one of the things that we did
when we studied Bigfoot was talk to a
Bigfoot expert that was playing us some
audio and some of the audio it sounds
like a samurai it sounds like the guy
was claiming that this was like a secret
recording of Bigfoot really oh my god it
was the dumbest thing I've ever heard
anything by the way in your conspiracy
theories yeah and like what you
challenged was there anything that you
ended up going oh like oh good question
not dumb yes really
yeah more challenge disease or George
Ellen's disease is a disease where
people is it more challenges I was
called but you're saying you deem it
yeah I thought it was [ __ ] before
cuz I had read that it was [ __ ] and
what I read was that the people would
think that they had things grown other
skin so they'd be scratching themselves
and they would add fibers to their skin
and take pictures of it and say look
I've got things growing out of my skin
and that it was a hoax but then talking
to a doctor who had more Jones who
explained to me that there's some sort
of neurotoxic effect of Lyme disease and
that everyone who has more Jones also
has Lyme disease yeah and he was a
legitimate doctor in a very smart guy
and he was essentially saying that
mainstream science in its rush to prove
he's gonna piss in that
come on man yeah but you're gonna get us
kicked off YouTube with your dick out
balls just cut straight Tuesday anyway
that that is a real disease that there's
more gel ins disease is what it is is
this Lyme disease the there's a bunch of
pathogens that come with Lyme disease
you know it's not just the Lyme disease
it's not like a pure one you know a one
or a zero either you have or you don't
it's a dirty tic there's a bunch of
[ __ ] horrible diseases inside this
nasty little body would you know if you
had limes yes you get a bull's-eye like
like looking red mark around the area
and the area hurts and then you start
experiencing terrible symptoms like
flu-like symptoms and okay you gotta
quit operating up the reefs opposed to
catch it quick rushes teeth and he's
like he couldn't like go back and forth
like what the [ __ ] my friend's kid got
Bell's palsy worst feature that that had
Bell's palsy in high school and they
kept him out and then he came back and
he was okay no but he he came back while
he still had the face paralysis like
looking at this dude we had a student a
year old to me art Bell's palsy and we
mocked them relentlessly like we should
have staged no that's on stage and his
face started going on him and he had to
hold his cheek over to finish his jokes
when he told his brother in lawyers I
think I'm having a stroke I'm about to
get on a plane with him I'm gonna stroke
the next morning his face was numb and
drooped and his brother-in-law goes go
to the [ __ ] doctor right now he means
you're having a 20-hour stroke and it
was Bell's palsy and so what do they do
about that
I think he's nothing [ __ ] nothing
just wait at it dude I get I wake up
gift at it Eddie IFFT a tattoo I think
it's a virus you'd be good at it palsy
every [ __ ] morning why have
you think of that
it's my ritual every more like God left
I thought he was doing still own
impression he said does he he got it
when he was young it sometimes it
doesn't go away whoa
and so he wrote so we're about three
months does it affect a spelling or
doesn't help
basically he looks better now I hung out
with him this weekend but uh so easy
back on stage back on stage he spent
like three weeks in his sister's
basement just being like it's never
gonna come back my career's over I can't
go onstage like he tried to do a show
and he said everyone was just staring at
it like this like oh so what do they do
to fix it nothing
you just wait you just wait till it
starts coming back yeah I think he said
reboot it was like right your face so
you gotta get kayoed wait so why do you
think about this every morning dude yeah
especially won't get ready for a special
I think like what if I got bells one
morning the morning of my special the
secret time I woke up and I smiled no
one I beat Bell's palsy that's the first
thought I had my involve in this
conversation I can't believe I'm
involved in this penalty palsy you know
what else I forget I think of alopecia
this hair sir everyone gets up every
little every comic at the store had it
burn had it I met I met had it everyone
got it at one point and I just was like
don't give all the hair fella just in a
circle normal at it we were scattered
when I was a kid yeah I think about
alopecia to it so I love a sin had it
never that's my thoughts away mike tyson
i like a weird circle in his head for a
while didn't know it yeah